YouTube's here the latest update to
youtube we all laughed when it came we
all thought huh another stupid idea from
YouTube it won't matter it will matter
for [ __ ] but we were wrong while you all
left guess who signed up for YouTube
heroes that's right this guy and since I
have 49 million subscribers it means I
qualify for the highest rank oh yeah
YouTube lets me to combat clickbait edit
anyone's titles on YouTube and you know
who cares more about clickbait than
anyone oh you guessed that again yes so
we're gonna send sir everyone else's
videos and put what the real title is on
their shitty clickbait videos together
today it's gonna be a fun time leave it
like at any point during you enjoy this
video if you feel like huh yeah that's
the like for it video let's begin first
speed Oh girls answer it's size matters
oh no it doesn't that's a straight-up
lie you look down that means you're
lying
what's that again no it does not as
important but I think is more just admit
it if a guy is very well-endowed he
doesn't try as hard just see really how
you work it way to dodge the question
okay how about this girls don't answer
if size matters they avoid the [ __ ]
question and straight-up lie about it I
have a butthole and you think I can't
tell if this comes in or if this comes
in are you get are you serious right now
I mean I haven't done it I haven't tried
it but if I wanted to try it
listen I don't even have to try it in no
way shut up I I have it no maybe the
pinky finger ones just to see what it
was shut up what is this video about
clickbait right next one should you live
with your crush well we got a flat ass
here on the left pull out ass
on the left but apparently you'll still
click I mean not that there's anything
wrong with flat ass don't get me wrong I
don't want to offend anyone I don't want
people to feel bad if they watch my
video especially not about their
physical appearance but Jesus Christ
it's like a pancake should you get butt
implants that's the better title you're
welcome see I'm helping you now also
also a thing that I noticed which i
think is really funny is that someone
some some other schmuck at BuzzFeed made
this thumbnail and there was no text
there was no text on it there was just
this image and the person thought you
know what it needs it needs to say [ __ ]
there but we need to censor we need to
censor it because we're buck were
breastfeeding a bunch of bunch of kooks
so let's add [ __ ] and let's add a
little let's add a little brush effect
yeah that's it it's like oh oh what a
great thumbnail but you know what it
misses [ __ ] no no no no no no no no
there ya go oh no no no no no no no oh
oh oh oh [ __ ] dog oh man oh oh yes first
feed now what was this video about it I
forgot I keep I keep forgetting all
right yoga challenge with my girlfriend
I swear I've seen this somewhere else
oh yeah chubbs tweeted okay here's the
title dry humping my girlfriend for
views in front of my audience of 10 year
olds now that's that's pretty accurate
at least wait is this Roman Atwood my
job as a YouTube hero this is this is
too much effort okay we'll just change
them all emotionally manipulating my
audience of eight-year-olds I'm moving
to England really wait what I'm going to
England for my book tour
oh okay so I'm a [ __ ] liar there you
go getting GTA 6 early you won't believe
this this youtuber got GTA 6 early you
won't believe what happens getting GTA 6
Earl
man I didn't know GTA community was so
[ __ ] cancer sorry YouTube should
delete my channel top five youtubers who
almost died women and land steward
comedyshortsgamer Oh top five youtubers
who should have done
that's not funny PUD hey I'm quitting
YouTube forever well I'm not gonna click
on this video I repeat you know what I
refuse but I'm gonna bet my my left nut
that leafy is not quitting because they
never quit youtubers don't quit and for
a very simple reason and since it's a
beautiful thing okay that's the title
Adsense is a beautiful thing I will
never quit YouTube as long as it keeps
giving me that's sweet juice I wish it
would pay a lot more but hey that
doesn't mean I'm gonna quit you know
what I'll eat my left testicle
if the leafy quits and never uploads the
video I'm serious 100% I'm saying right
now it's not a call-out I will eat my
left testicle
I quit for now I like all right there I
got this one boohoo my life is so hard
being a millionaire thanks to YouTube
done oh and I'm done
oh boy being a youtube hero sure it's a
lot of work I didn't realize how [ __ ]
[ __ ] the clickbait on YouTube is until I
asked I asked people to send me the
worst cuz it's said YouTube's 2016
minutes it's been a good it's been a
good year for clickbait this has been me
fixing clickbait titles you are welcome
it's been my pleasure and if you if you
smiled any time at this video go ahead
and leave a like and I'll see Bros in
the next video and as always leave a
like